i think it's important in the beginning
to really focus
on what you stand for and i think it's
important to say no to opportunities
that don't really fit your vision
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
this one is all about drinks and a lot
of them
welcome raisa de haas the co-founder of
double dutch
joyce and ryza are the dynamic twin
co-founders of award-winning uk premium
tonic and mixers
brand double dutch since launching in
they have received numerous accolades
with serve richard branson supporting
their vision by awarding them
a coveted footprint award additional
honors include being featured in the
telegraph's top 50 most ambitious
business leaders in 2019
and taking a spot on the prestigious
forbes 30 under 30 europe list
in just a few years they have built a
multi-million pound business where most
recently
also the family heineken invested and
minorities taken
raise at the house thank you for joining
me how are you
i'm very well how are you i'm doing
fantastic thank you i'm excited to talk
to you about consumer brands
about double dutch about you know
creating a
a new type of beverage out of london and
forbes 30 under 30. a little bit about
your journey a little bit about the
insights
and you know i've gotten to get you know
inspired and
very much appreciative of building
strong consumer brands and how difficult
it is and how
you know both concentrated the market is
but also how you know
how it's difficult to be differentiated
from others and and everything about you
know
about food tech and being innovative
there it's getting more and more
difficult so
so reza start me off with your journey
how do you get to
you know build a company called double
dutch
so i started double edge about five
years ago together with my twin sister
and we are dutch
and his name double h um and we always
kind of know
growing up in in the netherlands which
is the birthplace of gin
we always kind of build up a big passion
for spirits and chins and we grew up a
little bit prank
uh and our parents they organized lots
of tastings and we just
i don't know we just loved the good
thing but then when we
we kind of soon realized that choice of
tonic waters and mixers were super
limited
um and it was quite boring there was
premium tonic waters and premium
premium existing flavors but nothing
really different
so my sister and i we just during our
years at university
we started making our own soft drinks um
in our kitchen
we uh brought it to like house parties
and when people went
came over to our place we always had our
own homemade sodas
and people started calling us the tonic
twins and that was it it was kind of a
fun hobby hobby but never really thought
about doing anything serious with it um
so then i we both studied uh
similar i studied in moscow in economics
and my sister uh mastering in finance
so we graduated and we kind of both went
into similar banking finance worlds
but we soon realized that that was not
really for us
so we quit our jobs after six months and
we decided to move to london
to study a second master at ucl in
london together
so there was a one year master in tech
entrepreneurship
and the idea of that was to kind of
devote your year about
building a startup in the fintech space
but we came to london and we saw
chilean tonics was massively booming
even more than back
at home the choice of tonic waters was
as limited as back home
so we also university can't we skip the
whole fintech
space and just do it about something
that we are really passionate about and
write a dissertation about the drinks
industry so they said yeah fine
whatever your whatever you want to do um
so we did a year of market research with
lots of bartenders and consumers and
kind of looking at
where the opportunities laid and then uh
graduated with the concept of double
edge so more
innovative tonic waters that were 100
natural they were lower in calories
and more particularly focused around
cocktails and not just the gin and tonic
on its own and then our university ucl
gave us a price for best thesis of the
year
and with that they gave us our initial
investments but one of the requirements
to get that
kind of free funding was to stay in the
uk and start double that
in london
and we just thought let's give it a try
we'll see how it go goes and then
went really well from the start we got
some good awards from the beginning
richard branson
voted us as best um uh food and beverage
band and that kind of gave us national
press
um he flew us over to the us to pitch
for target and gave us lots of
mentorship and kind of
build it from there amazing okay so
i i love how you know you know listen to
you talk about that right now
three or four minutes it makes it sound
almost like easy they say that yeah sure
you know go study a degree in finance
then go
you know study a little bit of take
entrepreneurship do some market research
and boom you've got a whole
you know a consumer brand in front of
you but that's not really the case is it
so tell me a little bit about you know
the complexity
of creating this new brand because you
know obviously
sure you can mix the drinks you can do
your signs and everything
and but then you have to have people
actually want to drink it and buy it
and you have competition and you're
standing on an aisle with you know
dozens of others of other colorful
brands and so how do you actually go
about thinking okay like how do we
actually get people to
to buy into this
uh i think it's really i think
you're completely right i think it's
quite competitive markets um
and i think it's difficult to build a
brand i think it's probably easier if
you just want to shift volumes but
building a long-term brand
takes time as well i think it's really
important
from the start to focus on a really
niche market for example for us
we focused on only the five-star hotels
and the cocktail bars in mayfair
we didn't even really soho garden which
was
300 meters further we literally kind of
built it from
a tiny geographic area with a small
consumer base
and then and why is that so why
why that strategy i think it helped us
other people other customers like um
hospitality venues they thought we were
probably a little bit bigger than we
were because we had some really
good customer base with well-known uh
bars and restaurants in a super tiny
influential area
so people that came from also bartenders
and and people
in the industry that came from abroad
about uh outside of that area they saw
us
they thought all those amazing bars all
of mayfair is talking them but
i mean we maybe had five or six dog it's
not lost um
then we'll start stocking it and kind of
build it from there i think it's
important
in the beginning to really focus on
what you stand for and i think it's
important to say no to opportunities
that don't really fit your vision
and i think it's easy to for example get
lost and
maybe um if there we had when we were
really
uh when we were three months um young
are in into our business uh kind of low
end
uh supermarket market asked us to list
us and it would have been
game changing in terms of volumes back
then but i think it would have really
hurt our brand so
i think it's important especially in the
beginning to be able to say no to
um to things that aren't or your
specific vision
right and how do you like do you do any
you know av testing or
how do you actually get feedback about
you know the actual brand that you're
creating i mean
then you're creating you know a bottle
that has a label and people
want to have that label on their house
right so how do you actually go about
you know creating sort of this landing
page
for your physical brand what is that
process like for you
i think it's very much style and error
when we first launched
we knew that we were launching with a
product that we
wasn't 100 finished in terms of um
of products but we kind of knew 100
sure that the labels and the kind of
branding around it was so far from
finished
but we had to launch because living in
london is very expensive and we just
needed to start
selling uh but i think in the inside it
was quite good that we launched with
something that wasn't finished because
we got real market feedback and we got
what we thought we would got the
feedback that our labels needed
improvements
but we didn't really know in what kind
of way and by
selling actually people told us you
should involve like
for example our story more on there uh
you should involve
the the fact that chains were originally
um coming from
the netherlands that's quite a good uh
fit
that we were younger so it needed to
kind of be more colorful in our branding
creation so i and then we after
four months of launch we changed our
branding completely and we changed our
design
we also slightly kind of optimized our
storytelling a little bit as well
um just kind of by listening to our
customers
so now still if we launch a product we
launch with
uh recipes now that we do stand behind
but we're always open to we always
produce quite a small batch in the
beginning
and then we change maybe minor things in
our next patch
based on feedback so how many people are
actually a part of this team
and this double dutch team that is made
of joyce and raza right
yeah yeah there were 20 people in total
uh certified
small still but growing um and i think
for us we have always had a very
outsourced business model so we work
with third party manufacturers we don't
uh do we work with for example pr
agencies events agencies
we work with lots of agencies outsourced
um which probably
will keep doing we'll see but but race
tell me a little bit about you know the
most challenging things that you have to
encounter because until now it sounds
like a cinderella story you you go to
school you say we have to make money so
we're going to launch we're going to
sell
and you're quickly considered like you
know the
you know the go-to gin experts you're
coming from the birthplace of jen and
and you automatically start selling to
these you know five-star you know hotels
and restaurants so how do you actually
you know what what are the biggest
challenges that
you've had along this path that you had
to overcome and say like wow like i
didn't anticipate this
i didn't expect this
i think the biggest challenge in the
beginning was that
so we were very much focused on the
hospitality industry so they didn't
really look at retail in the beginning
and i think what we also after doing a
year of research to it we
didn't realize that bars and restaurants
don't buy from brands
directly they buy from wholesalers right
it was kind of a chicken already
you can end the egg problem because a
wholesaler won't list you
if you don't have hospitality buying you
right the hospitality won't buy you
until you're a wholesaler
and i think that definitely was super
difficult
um and eventually we we signed an
exclusivity deal with one wholesaler we
agreed like terrible terms on
sale and return uh with terrible pricing
but then
from there on it was it kind of went
definitely easier after having your
first wholesaler
on board and i think also just in the
beginning getting
first customers on board because right
people always want a brand that's
already that's already having some kind
of distribution
especially the high-end places um so i
think
marketing and building loyalty and
getting to people's hearts
without having the big marketing budgets
that other carpets have
is definitely a struggle and i think the
only way to get through it is
persistence and
getting loads of noise uh before you get
your first yes
right and kind of building from there
and and raisa
so right now you're you're selling in
europe and uk i'm guessing that
you know part of it is coming from from
online and part of it but it's coming
from physical stories is that how it
works
uh so the majority of our business or at
least that was uh prickowitz was coming
from the hospitality industry so bars
and restaurants
but now obviously that's changed a lot
we
we do have quite a good number of
retailers and physical stores
online wasn't really ever something that
we focused on at all
uh which i think an insight was such a
lost
uh channel that we just never looked
after so i i do think
now we have been we've been developing
our own d2c channel but also working a
lot closer with for example amazon and
ocados and online amazing
um i think it's a great way to build
loyalty and connect with your direct
consumers
so i i love it and
tell me a little bit about about this
the vision that you have here because
obviously growing a brand is it
you know it takes a lot of time and when
you're building this brand
and you know that it's growing and
growing so is there a greater vision
for for double dutch do you see yourself
you know being like the go-to gin
um you know gin mixer you know
a commodity within the uk in europe how
do you see it think for us we really
want to become a household name
in the mixed itonic water market knowing
for slightly more innovation
um and excitement into the mixer
category
uh for us definitely our home market is
the uk
and will stay the uk um so we're trying
to become the number
um two in the uk and number three in
europe
by driving univ innovation um but also
experts for example asia has been really
important now during kovitz
there's lots of opportunities there
right in the e-commerce
um and we're launching this year also in
the u.s
uh so that's exciting okay so first of
all so i can't wait to order my
my batch all the way to california so
i'm already excited about that
and tell me a little bit about you know
what you and your team are
really excited about because you're
coming from finance you and your twin
sister you're both studying economics
and finance
it's not the linear trajectory or the
expected trajectory you're going to go
into this beverage
space so does that play a role do you
use what you knew from finance and
economics and what you do now
um between my sister and i i look after
sales and marketing and justice
everything with finance and operations
so i think probably joyce still uses
some of it um
i probably forgot everything by now um
uh i don't know i don't think that um in
all honesty
like general studies are massively
helpful but i do think that our
last year in entrepreneurship that
really helped us because we learned
little tiny pieces of starting up a
company
um so yeah uh
i think that the the general overall
um uh unders i think understanding the
basics is important
uh but it's definitely not a necessity
right
if there was something that you know if
i were to come into your offices or talk
to your team members
and you look at your business what will
be something that just surprises me
that i'm like like wow this is like cool
this is new i like i didn't anticipate
this except for the fact that it's
you know twin sisters that are not from
the uk that are launching an alcoholic
beverage in the uk
um i think um
[Music]
if you come into our office you'll
probably see over 300 bottles of spirits
so it's probably more than your average
300.
wow and do you guys enjoy drinking it as
well
yes of course but we also think it's
uh just on its own not always with
alcohol
i love it no no i think that's fantastic
right so what would be something that
you would tell
you know young people around the world
that are thinking of starting their
business you know most of the people
that i talk to are in technology they're
in startups
and and but this is very different it's
not and it's different
in perhaps the way you approach the
problem and solve it
but it's not different in the mindset
it's not different in the curiosity you
need to have
the resilience you need to have and the
passion you need to bring to what you do
so what would be something that you
would advise you know young people
around the world are saying i want to
start my own business it may be
technology it may not be
maybe i want to start a food chain or
you know a new
type type of pencil what would be
something that they should keep in mind
i think first of all just start and get
out and
develop an uh kind of mvp small
prototype something
and just start selling because i think
lots of people wait and try to
perfectionize their product or service
or whatever it is
with friends and family but you're never
gonna get the almost real feedback that
you're gonna get by
trying to sell it and get paying
customers so i would i think the good
thing with small
companies and starting companies is also
that people 100 forgive you and think
it's quite
nice actually that you take their
feedback into account and
they forgive you that you're changing
your product so i would understand just
go out and start selling and i think
secondly i think it's so important to
surround yourself
with cave people so in the beginning
when you don't have a team yet
try to describe yourself um with mentors
or co-founders
or anyone who can help you go in your
entrepreneurial journey
right did you have that that mentorship
that sort of like your personal board of
directors
that you go to for advice throughout
this whole process
um yeah now we have a great board of
directors um
and in the beginning we i think joyce
and i
because we were sisters we have quite a
lot on each other kind of a bit more
as a general of
better to celebrate the ups but also
kind of to pick each other up in the
downs
um and i think we always had two or
three really kids
mentors from outside of the company that
were helping us as a more
overall broader strategic few are
helping us with introductions and then
networking kind of
taking us under their their wings so
that really helped us a lot in the
beginning
i love it race i know that you have to
go and i really appreciate you being
uh you know being so generous with your
time with me and sharing with me your
story i can't wait to see
and to see where double dutch takes you
and i think that you know
first of all going going through this
journey with your sister i think is
it's both and i'm sure that it's an
incredible journey i'm sure that it's
also a difficult one in a lot of areas
but
but i can't imagine how close it must
bring the tv together and i and i think
the innovative part of what you're doing
and obviously you want you're winning
all these awards and the fantastic
launch and the fantastic traction
you know number two in london soon and
number three in europe i think that
that's just
incredible and and i can't wait to see
it now spreading all the way in the
united states
so really thank you for taking the time
to be here with me i really appreciate
it
i do have the most important question
which is the three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um passionate hard-working
and resourceful
resourceful i mean i need one word about
that why resourceful
um i don't know kind of
finding new opportunities problem
solving um
not really very much uh looking
kind of more looking into the class is
always half full rather than half empty
and looking into solutions
i don't think there's i don't really
accept notes in
um in for example pictures or
um just think persistence maybe
i love it risa thank you very very much
stay safe and stay healthy
and and best of luck with double dutch i
look forward to seeing it
you too thank you so much of course
thank you thank you